castiel star Washington DC you're here
at friendship park because today
launches the historical caravan for
peace we're going to go from Friendship
Park as we cross the entire country till
sep tember 12 we're going to be in
Washington DC and we're doing this
caravan for peace because there's five
issues that we're dealing with want to
change the drug policy of this country
the arms trafficking the money
laundering some of the foreign policy of
this country and immigration reforms
those are the five themes that were
focused on and we're starting at this
historic location because here's where
Mexico in the United States meet and
we're going to be heading all the way
across the country so tomorrow we'll go
to LA then Arizona and Mexico etc it's
called a caravan for peace with justice
and dignity even though what led by
donkeys be saving because the costs
associated with fighting the drug war
are too much for society to bear and
it's time that there's people like me
I'm a registered Republican I'm a woman
I'm a grandmother on the mother who
recognizes that that this rhetorical war
has a cost for society that is just
tremendous
laughter thank goodness I vieras already
done two of these in Mexico now we're
doing one of the United States because
we need to be working together on these
issues por la paz con gusta saving